We are on problem 7.
Let me draw what they
have drawn.
They drew a right triangle.
The right triangle looks
something like this.
And then they drew
another triangle.
And it looks like an isosceles
triangle, although we can't
assume anything in this life.
Nothing comes for free.
So this is x.
This is y.
u, v, w.
Those are the angles.
In the triangles above, what
is the average-- arithmetic
mean-- of u, v, w, x, and y?
So you have to just add up the
sum of the angles and then
divide by the number
of angles.
So we want to take u plus v plus
w plus x plus y, and then
divide by the number
of angles.
So there's one, two, three,
four, five angles.
First question.
What is u plus v plus w?
Well, they form the angles in
a triangle, so they're going
to add up to 180 degrees.
And what's x plus y?
Well, it's a right triangle.
And all three of these angles
have to add up to 180.
x plus y plus this 90 have
to add up to 180.
So x plus y is going
to be equal to 90.
Just subtract 90 from
both sides.
So x plus y is equal to 90.
So if we take the sum of the
top, 180 plus 90, that's 270.
Divided by 5.
5 goes into 270-- 5,
25, 7, 20, 54.
So the average is 54 degrees.
That's the arithmetic mean
of all of those angles.
And that is choice E.
Next problem.
I just inadvertently switched
back to my bad-luck yellow.
All right.
Problem 8.
Looks like they've drawn--
It looks like a ray.
I'm going to put an
arrow on one side.
Let me switch colors.
They say that this is
x to the third.
This is x squared.
This is x.
If x, x squared, and x to the
third lie on a number line in
the order shown above, which of
the following could be the
value of x?
So the first thing we know, x
has got to be-- well, the
first thing we know, that
x is a positive number.
How do I know that?
Because if x was not a positive
number-- well, let me
think about that.
Right.
x has to be a positive number.
Because-- let me put
it this way.
If any negative number-- let's
say it's negative 1/2.
If you square negative 1/2,
you get positive 1/4.
So for any negative number,
the square is going to be
bigger than the number itself.
So we know that x is
greater than 0.
That's one thing we know.
What else do we know?
We also know that x is going
to be less than 1.
How do I know that?
Because x squared
is less than x.
And that only applies for
numbers less than 1.
Because 1/2 squared is
equal to 1/4, and 1/4
is less than 1/2.
So we also know that
x is less than 1.
So we just have to find a choice
where x is greater than
0 and less than 1.
And if we look at the choices,
greater than 0 and less than
1, there's only one choice
that that applies to.
And that's 3/4.
Choice C.
You might want to say 3/2,
but that's 1 and 1/2.
That's greater than 1.
The first two choices
are negative.
The last two choices are greater
than 1-- or greater
than or equal to 1.
So we know it's choice C.
Next problem.
And if you didn't want to do it
in an abstract way, and if
you have a lot of time, if
you're really fast on the
problems you do know
how to do, you can
always try out the numbers.
But that takes longer.
They drew a coordinate
system right here.
And this is my y-axis.
This is the x-axis.
And then they draw a line that
goes through the origin.
And then they tell us that this
point right here is the
point 1 comma 3.
So this is 1.
This is 3.
And what do they want
us to do with this?
In the figure above, line l
passes through the origin.
This is line l.
What is the value of k/h?
Oh, and then they label
another point here.
They say this is h comma k.
So what is the value
of k divided by h?
So the y value over the
x value, right?
And I'm going to tell you right
now, the value of it is
going to be the slope
of this line.
And how do we know that?
If you wanted to figure out the
slope from the origin to
this point, what would it be?
The origin of course is 0, 0.
So it would be change in y.
Change in y is 0 minus k.
You wouldn't have to
do this on the SAT.
I just want to show you that
it would be the slope.
And then change in x
would be 0 minus h.
And that of course is equal
to minus k over minus h.
The negatives cancel out,
and that equals k/h.
So they're essentially just
asking us, what is the slope
of this line?
Well, that's easy enough,
because it
gives us another point.
And so we can say, well, we
could do this rise over run.
So here, what is the
change in y?
Change in y is equal
to 3 minus 0.
I'm taking this as kind
of the initial point.
3 minus 0.
Change in x is 1 minus 0.
So change in y over change
in x is equal to 3.
And that's our slope, and
that's our answer.
So the answer is A.
Next problem.
Problem 10.
They're saying the absolute
value of m minus
3 is equal to 5.
They're also telling us that the
absolute value of k plus 7
is equal to 15.
In the equations above,
m is less than 0 and k
is less than 0.
What is the value
of m minus k?
So m is less than 0, right?
So there's two possibilities
here.
This first equation, if we
didn't see that, it could mean
two different things.
You could say m minus 3 is equal
to 5 or m minus 3 is
equal to negative 5.
This one would solve to m is
equal to 8, and this one would
solve to m is equal
to minus 2.
Well, we know m is not 8,
because m is less than 0.
And to solve this, I just
added 3 to both sides.
So we know that m is minus 2.
Similarly, let's take that
second equation.
That tells us that k plus 7 is
equal to 15, or k plus 7 is
equal to minus 15.
Subtract 7 from both sides of
this, you get k equals 8.
Subtract 7 from both sides
of this, you get k is
equal to minus 22.
And they tell us that k
is also less than 0.
So we know that this is k.
And they want us to know
what m minus k is.
Well, m is minus 2,
and k is minus 22.
So minus 2 minus minus 22.
So that's the same thing
as minus 2 plus 22.
And that is of course 20.
And that is choice E.
I will see you in
the next video.